У палаті - як у вулику.
Та пацієнти обговорюють не стільки свої хвороби, як чутки про те, закриють їхню лікарню чи ні.
Це терапевтичне відділення для дорослих
районної лікарні Хорошівського району Житомирської області.
Бабусю Ольгу сюди поклали через високий тиск та завищений рівень цукру.
Мене привезли нікудишню, а поки б то мене заперли в Житомир. Там я б богу душу віддала.
І не вздумайте її закривати.
Розмови про можливе закриття п'ятиповерхової районної лікарні точаться давно,
та зараз вони ожили з новою силою.
Адже з першого квітня стартує реформа вторинної ланки медицини.
Це означає, що повністю змінюється система фінансування районних лікарень.
Раніше медзаклад отримував від держави медичну субвенцію -
щорічну фіксовану суму, яка не залежала від кількості та якості наданих послуг.
З квітня гроші йтимуть за кожен пролікований випадок.
Для цього Національна служба здоров’я України сформувала вимоги до лікарень,
які можуть претендувати на оплату медичних послуг.
У програші передусім лікарні, які мають застаріле технічне оснащення.
Ми відповідаємо вимогам НСЗ в тому, що ми не маємо послуг,
які будуть надаватись в пріоритеті і які оплачуються дорого.
Це послуги комп’ютерного томографа, МРФ, ангіографа.
Такого високоякісного обладнання ми не маємо.
Держава нас не забезпечила і не передбачила, і цього не зробила.
Тому в пріоритеті ми не будемо йти.
Ми будемо отримувати за діагностично споріднені групи,
це менша оплата, і, відповідно, менше коштів ми отримаємо.
Тож головна лікарка переймається, за які кошти буде утримувати лікарню.
Будівля збудована ще за радянських часів,
коли витрати на персонал і комунальні послуги ніхто не рахував.
Нині лише опалення та освітлення безкінечно довгих коридорів
коштує чимало  - 2,5 мільйона гривень.
І це типова ситуація для багатьох районів, яким у спадок залишились подібні будівлі.
Зі зміною фінансування витрати,
зокрема і за комуналку, лягатимуть на бюджети місцевих громад.
А ті неохоче беруть на себе цей тягар.
В Хорошівській райлікарні, наприклад, лікуються мешканці трьох об’єднаних територіальних громад,
то чому ж утримувати її повинна лише одна громада, міркує селищний голова.
Як вижити в нових умовах, він ще поки не знає.
Хтось каже, давайте купимо томограф, бо будуть платити за кожен пролікований інсульт.
А для того щоб встановити інсульт - крововилив у мозок, - треба зробити томографію.
Якщо томограф коштує сьогодні, наприклад 7,5 млн гривень,
ну, мабуть, установка не менше семи мільйонів, то ми сьогодні повинні прорахувати.
Тим більше, що сьогодні в обласному центрі є
інсультний центр, інфарктний центр.
Тобто, там є вже, де зібране устаткування,
де зібрані нормальні кадри, які, звісно, зразу готові надавати спеціалізовану допомогу.
Тому це все треба прораховувати.
Підрахувати, скільки буде, так би мовити, "заробляти" районна лікарня
з мінімальним пакетом послуг наразі неможливо.
Адже Національна служба здоров’я досі не встановила тарифи,
що ще більше непокоїть районні лікарні.
- Де бабушки з шостої палати історія? - Ось.
Це вже Пулинська районна лікарня, яка за двадцять кілометрів від Хорошева.
Як і тамтешня лікарня, вона поки фінансується з району
і не належить жодній з чотирьох місцевих ОТГ.
Щороку  фінансові діри латались за рахунок переговорів з чиновниками різних рівнів.
Поки це вдавалось.
Якби не було підтримки з боку районної ради і наших ОТГ, то не було б у нас лікарні.
Якщо щось треба, я безпосередньо йду чи до одного, чи до іншого голови ОТГ.
Поспілкувалися, надали лист про потребу та й, у принципі, все.
Наші ОТГ мають фінансування, вони мають кошти і найголовніше, що вони підтримують нас.
Послуги в обох лікарнях надаються практично однакові.
Проте у Пулинах за рахунок компактних приміщень економлять на утриманні.
У перерві між операціями хірург та головний лікар розповідає, як буде виживати в майбутньому.
Зокрема він прагне розвивати у лікарні неврологічний напрямок,
що дозволить в майбутньому отримувати більше фінансування від Національної служби здоров'я.
Якщо буде вигідна тарифна сітка, запрацює і паліативна допомога.
Втім, будь-які зміни можливі за фінансової підтримки голів громад.
Сьогодні в законі чітко не прописано, що ми зобов'язані це робити,
але як ми тут живемо на місці і не вистачає коштів, ми можемо так поступити.
Просто по-іншому вчинити неможливо.
І, звичайно, хотілося б, щоб пропорційно проплачували інші громади.
На жаль, не всі це робили, через те нам трошки важкувато.
Ми в деякій мірі лікуємо людей не з нашої громади за наші гроші.
В Національній службі здоров'я України кажуть,
ідея реформи полягає в тому, аби долю медичних закладів вирішувала місцева влада,
а не профільне міністерство в Києві.
Буцімто на місці видніше, яку допомогу розширити, яку скоротити.
Самі ж пацієнти в провінції наразі і першу фазу медичної реформи ще не цілком осмислили.
Для багатьох зміни, ініційовані владою, не є покращенням.
Незручно, незручно.
От я виписую сину інсулін.
Виходить, хвора людина.
Прийти сюди на прийом - треба йти назад туди, щоб там виписали. Тут лікар виписав у картці.
Туди треба йти, щоб виписали рецепт, назад треба йти до лікаря, щоб підписав.
І йти отуди назад в аптеку, щоб отримати.
То це геть невигідно.
Раніше все було тут, а тепер - туди йди, туди йди до спеціаліста вищого і так далі.
Не зовсім... Я то на машині, а там он люди з палкою. Поки зайшов, взяв картку,
прийшов сюди - це проблема.
Усі види досліджень і рентген знімки і УЗД в нас є.
Так що для району це ще дуже добре.
Ймовірне закриття багатьох районних лікарень
за відсутності зручної інфраструктури та якісних доріг
в перспективі додатково ускладнить життя багатьом пацієнтам.
Чи не найбільше постраждають хворі похилого віку.